My name is PewDiePie. I am a Maverick. I am a savage!!
I am a legend. I am....
a MAAADMAAAN!!
You never know what I'm going to do next..
*Applause*
I am a mad. lad.
So I told Dean to lay down on the floor.
He actually did it!
Absolute...
madman!
HAHAHA
I may be a mad lad, but I will never be as mad as Dean.
Just laying on the floor.
Watching the Friends intro,
Without
clapping!
ABSOLUTE MADMAN!
No he did not absolutely-
He did not.
*F.R.I.E.N.D.S theme plays*
*Clap 5x*
I CAN'T HELP IT!
You did what?
I do weird things in the holidays, like eat bowls of pasta...
...randomly....
ABSOLUTE!
MAD!
LAD!
Eating bowls of pasta!
RANDOMLY!!
I can't..
I can't keep up with this! *giggles*
Absolute savage. .
Absolute Maverick. Someone call the police!!
This dude at the noodle place is really about to yell out order number...
...69!
And I'm about to f'ing sshhhhhitting! *Holds Head in disbelieve*
Thas the GOD DAMN SEX NUMBER!
AND HE'S ABOUT TO YELL  IT OUT
*covers mouth* in front of everyone!
Mad lad.
(claps) Mad (claps) *Laughs*
Feminist vegan says meat is bad.
Then, Jesse Watters, WHIPS out a steak and eats it right in front of her!!
ABSOLUTE MAD LAD! That is crazy!.
Matty B Raps...
A well-known established mad lad... that I can only show my utmost respect for! What did he do this time?
What he did MattyBRaps...What kind of crazy thing did he do?
takes a lot of hard work...
and focus! In the studio. but in the end, it's all worth it!
hashtag
up late....
8:24 PM...
ABSOLUTE!!!!MAD LAD!!!! (Psychedelic Video Editing)
That's like ..... thas like way past his bedtime!
I bet you...  eight. seven....
But you didn't actually read the whole number. Neh...How did he know?
So I'm guessing you didn't see the letter in it
You just went back and checked and saw that I lied mwahhaha!
*Angry face* URRRRHRHHGHGHG
Neil deGrasse Tyson!  I occasionally free swivel 360
degrees in those over sized chairs, doing important board meetings...
Oh yeah?
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS?!
HAAHAHHA
Turns out the madman, got the mad lad ad
Heee pwah *Spits*.
Where are them Isis... C word
Literally me every single day.
I'm like I, ai, eyh
Arm slightly higher than normal, and then I think to myself
I sure hope there was an Isis member that i could...
Someone put on their on their car that they hate, peas!
an Absolute Mad Lad, _the_blessedone
Put..!
*throws hat again*
I, wore, a thong on my head at Coachella and literally no one NOTICED!
MAD WAHMAN!
Or is it still mad lad?
Mad Wham! absolute mad wham!
she wore a-
maybe. *heh*  just maybe no one wanted to point out cuz it wasn't really that funny and pretty disgusting to be honest..
An absolute outrageous prankster pranks his entire FaceBook page.
Megan Fox, naked look smiley face ....
troll face
from google image search *nods*
Absolutely-
Mad Lad! *laughing*
No.... Bruce
Bruce Green 4...
Bruce Green 4 did not just spend-
$35 at-
McDonald's at
3 a.m.
Absolute MADLAD respect!
My friend is so drunk, he's LITERALLY CLEANING MY ROOM!
MADNESS!
What uhmmm -
You can't clean someone else's room! Number, One, Rule!
I worked at Arby's for a summer and put at least one-
curly fry in every order of normy fries.
Is he CRAZY?  *laughs*
Oh my god. I stayed up till 10:00 on a school night. Just to watch this trailer. #Star Wars
Sometimes mad lads gotta make sacrifices for their mannery!
True mad lad!
To all the poeple who never thought I could do it,
Hashtag, F you
What are you doing?
JUST HANGING OUT.
Ordering a GRAIN of rice from Chinese Restaurant (LOL)
You can't just do that! You just ordered one? *gibberish*
Absolute madman!
That's incredible!
*snort*
No.....no! The mad lad-
stretches all across the world!
I always listen to Eminem even though there are so many swear words but i dont....
f-ing CARE! *middle finger emoji*
MAAAAD LAAAD!
Does this Man not care about monetizing his videos on YouTube?!
ABSOLUTE SAVAGE!
This guy's insane!
Can someone stop him? He used the  F YOU emoji!? That's like forbidden in most countries.
it's illegal in at least 54 states
I eat my ice cream with a fork.
*laugh*
WHAT THE FORK????!!!!
Hahahahahaha!
We got on a random bus....
How will they know how to get back?
Do they even know where the bus is going?
MAD LADS!
Playing Rocket League while Standing....
Absolute Madman! I can't even tell if he's standing or not.
*laughs*
Aw, this is just cringe... got a picture of me in git Gatewick airport holding
Ciroc vodka another one at the airport
Another one. ANOTHER Airport one mad land. You can't just take pictures! with the alcohol
That's the thing about mad lads. They don't care about the stakes. They don't care if you might go to jail forever
They have to express their mad lad!
WHY YES! I am having some milk and Bailey's with dark chocolate truffle at
11:30 p.m.
AND
What an absolute Mad Lad!
I think i realize
I think it finally sunk in...
I'm not cut out for this...
I'm not cut out to be a mad lad!
I will never be a mad lad. There's no way I can be this maverick and Savage
But damn it!
You know what?
If I want to be a mad lad there's nothing that can stop me
Thank you for watching this video!! if you're a mad lad leave a like, and if you're a mad man
Or wahman... or anything.... leave a like just leave a like and subscribe
We're almost at 60 million subscribers !if if we hit 60 million subscribers. I'm going to shave
one hair off my beard
Madman out!
Furious by Sum Wave - [Beats, Drum & Bass Music]